Thursday baby I've been making believe a
lot this we're back man we're back we're
back and you're not now and half late so
we're off to a good start
I was bait I was making believe for an
hour and a half too long the other day
it was actually an hour I timed it but
knows on half me and Josh time we said
three and I got there he just started
later hit three and I got there for 4:30
no I mean Josh knows what it's exactly
for I don't think 60 or 90 not good six
here nine he's not guy oh I told Josh
that I'm probably gonna walk out now
he's no come on I need this one I did
not good numbers like it's like my buddy
I hooked up with this gal and he's a big
boy and she was she was he looked at her
and they had some pretty hot sex and
then he looked at her she was standing
there and she she was a stout young lady
she was he went outside because she was
giving it she was giving him the what
for you understand okay is he's a big
strong guy and she was kind of giving it
back like meeting him halfway in the
bedroom kind of tossing him around he's
in love [ __ ] and he goes and he's got a
he's got a scale and he's got one of the
skills that measures your height too and
he made her get on and he goes Bubba
stand on the scale for thought bubbling
she was she was a little drunk and she
goes okay oh wow he clocked her in at 5
foot almost 3 5 foot almost 3 1 8686 6
pounds yup and he looked at her fabric
it was a lot of stuff and he looked
there he goes I can't glad the nerve of
her to get on this guess she went Wow
and he goes and he goes right man he
goes not good numbers probably not good
numbers and then he goes pretty boy but
impressive yeah he's use a little
bowling ball he hit me a little little
meatball yep call me and go see little
meatball call me and when I went 5/3 186
last night hold mine I know you did and
he goes yes I did and he measured her
man circular as well because who had the
only other persona as a scale to measure
people's height and weight like that a
psycho well he Dexter chin and now this
he's always he's always measuring
himself and by the way that's strange he
told me he told me he goes do I know oh
yeah how old is and he's 50 something
and and then he goes back in he went and
I'm hanging out with her and her pajamas
were hanging open and I
back in 4/3 so I was like that's
impressive enough for the human meatball
that's it
sometimes you know you know sometimes in
the devil works yeah
sometimes the nice mix it's spicy
meatballs I have had I have had
wonderful experiences with with strong
stout men oh that's where you were go
where math yeah whenever I said women
little too analytics with dick no say
where no come on dude no bro don't say
men well you've soand came up three
economies throne was like dude we can't
Bryant [ __ ] some muscular chick with
a dick in the bathroom or like you know
[ __ ]
well my buddy like it went are we gon
stage and like be flustered yes I'd be
like you know the original gay our Jimmy
Burke he had a wonderful young man named
Tucker who was a professional dancer
staying with him and Tucker was as gay
as it gets and an absolute treasure and
a hell of a dancer professional like
this dancers in this kid is Broadway
professional near don't care and oh and
and and and could do a standing backflip
and dunk a basketball
yeah but gay gay gay and Gerry Madden
I'm there with my with my other buddy
and Frank and a couple of guys and Jerry
goes should we tell them and I go what
and they go dad your boy Jimmy Burke I
go what about him and they go we were
getting drunk
caught him Bob slapping with Tucker and
I went what guys but they were kissing
hard yeah cuz they knew why cuz I knew
you were coming around the corner in me
know into and here I was after this is
I'm I was like my best friends 25 years
so I went I was like how would I know
now I'm not know that my best friend of
25 but then did you flash back and think
of some like God through all that right
so I just it was very interesting my
reaction cuz I felt betrayed by him like
he didn't tell me though I was like this
I don't know how to make sense of this
and I was just standing there like that
and they were talking to me yeah
I can't took his [ __ ] it
wouldn't I mean it change it would have
made sense cuz me and Jimmy used to bang
so that was you know what I'm saying
yeah do you how about last night I went
down a weird [ __ ] rabbit hole with on
YouTube that you have YouTube on TV cuz
you just watch on your phone you know
and I watched that movie Dracula untold
legit ass movie right but then I went on
YouTube to find though like the story of
the real Dracula you know how I know how
it started mm-hmm definitely drink
people's blood Diddy and they also gone
Vlad the Impaler diving in peril I also
call [ __ ] on that to where they said
he impaled two hundred men and they
showed like the the wood and how they
would do it you know long that would
take I've roamed through this in my head
I'm like you know long well they would
since you want to filter wood right but
let you see it the Impaler there I feel
like that well for like folklore no in
fact the Turks the Ottomans I think you
can do it I don't know if you can do it
to the masses like that and well
apparently the Ottomans would take sharp
sticks and take you know the you know
certain people and put them there
[ __ ] on the spike and sit you there
and you would just keep going down on it
yeah it's a bad bad way to die no I'm it
sounds terrible I'm sure people have I
just don't know if you're doing that the
masses like that but Vlad is usually
don't use a terrible person he may have
been a serial killer who had the ability
to do these things a leader and he may
have drunk blood
he might have drunk blood but I don't
think he was like a straight vampire
well do you know you don't know that
this guy cut his head off uh-huh
and then he's buried now in Transylvania
that's where all of it starts yeah but
he came back because he's the undead I
don't know but they say that the last
sort of step for a serial killer
no let's look oh my god they say that
the last goddamn they say that the last
step for a serial killer is to drink
your blood like that's the one they've
really got over the edge no is it just
you Jeffrey Dahmer says hold my beer I'm
gonna eat your day well he was well
there's that
yeah yeah so oral eat your brain
drinking blood or drill into your head
while you're alive yeah and then drink
from there yeah though there's that
there is that yeah you know they were
going I like I started the I forget that
the girls
Amy something on YouTube but she goes
she like explores all these places I
just went down this weird rabble then I
found out I was watching the real Texas
Chainsaw murder like I like to find out
the real story behind that and that
comes from a real dude sure would like
weirder [ __ ] skin and stuff like that
my mother would always say anything you
can think of has been done to another
human being
leave this dude yeah he was the real
touched chainsaw murder he they get that
thing you know and the movies all
deformed stuff like that this guy would
weird people's skin yeah man what a [ __ ]
what a bad man the movies based off that
crazy dude now does he look like Brian's
older brothers yes you know that right a
little bit just like Frank Allen a
little more thicker jaw he's a little
thicker maybe in the face well you know
the the guy who shot a bunch of people
in a tower Charles Whitman I think his
name was Charles Whitman what he got up
and shot a shitload of people from a
tower snipe them and it was really
terrible one of the first shooting there
it is
one of the one of the first shooting a
mass shootings you know but he in Texas
right and he shot did he shoot yeah like
step takes you know he lives in the
slayings of his mother and his wife and
they were set back of homes and then
went to the University of Texas in
Austin with multiple firearms began
shooting people how many people did he
kill all together those in 1966 they're
dealing with this bull yeah but here's
what they found out when they did an
autopsy on his brain he had a brain
tumor
oh is that ways that flattop yes nobody
had a brain tumor that was apparently I
guess you know pushing on a part of a
game that was yeah there's this weird
thing where you can work teen people's
and funk
yeah you can have a lesion on your brain
the size if it's in the right place you
can have a lesion on your brain the size
of a pinprick the head of a pin and it
can turn you into a homicide
you can have one lesion it's so much now
they say - with CTE brain trauma - can
change certain things in your brain work
you know that like if you watch that jr.
sale documentary he goes from like this
loving great dude into the justice like
mm-hmm
strange violent checked out her he went
from dad of the year to like just
non-existent and his daughter said she
looked down right before he died I was
like oh my god the thumb at that my
dad's not in there no yeah cuz she said
she would like cry before and I shoot
you in trouble with her mom and he would
like shoot by discipline her and he
would take her by Kate act like you're
sad right like he was the best dad he's
like act like you're sad you're not
gonna be in trouble just don't get me in
trouble with your mom which is what I do
and so he like give her cookies or
whatever and she's like my dad was the
best and then right before he died like
a week before she went over to plead
dumb health he's like checked out and
used to be the best and she starts
crying he says she's just literally
staring through it while she's crying
she's like what the [ __ ] no that's
where's where's my dad where's pop at
it's so sad you know that Dick Cheney
apparently so so heart surgery can
change your personality fundamentally
yeah
and Dick Cheney well before he had his
heart surgery apparently was a really
kind of lucky happy-go-lucky
nice guy had heart surgery and the fake
heart I guess and had it and just
changed completely changed yeah and they
said he became almost like cold blooded
like once he had the heart transplant
like even his family like completely
different do you hear way more cold
anymore like yep it changes you yeah
that did the guy Robert I studied the
guy who got struck by lightning and
became obsessed with music and became an
incredible piano player but someone
struggle I like now they speak like a
break or some [ __ ] there's that there's
big stories like that where you get
struck by lightning and it'll cause some
crazy change but he couldn't stop
listening to music a piano and couldn't
stop playing the piano and became a
really good piano player and saying we
refused to study his brain because he
said it's a sign from God she's heart
transplant man I know when I get a lot
of sleep and drink a lot of coffee I
want a [ __ ] so that's there that makes
that change don't you into that like you
tackle and hide but yeah [ __ ] I wanna
[ __ ] oh wow I mean so that's what
happens to me I have by the way I'll bet
I have a little too much energy lately
now you know I'm an energetic guy but I
sleeping but before I do I've been
eating oysters is that what they did
they tell you that with your diet or no
I don't I'm fancy boy it's something up
noise that night in Fenton fancy and do
you rip the worst part no oysters don't
do that oh but I eat oysters and then
I'll have like sprouted broccoli or some
[ __ ] yeah yeah as long as I sleep enough
scope but as long as I eat if I see if I
sleep and I have coffee and have like
and I I just know I'm not doing the red
meat or alcohol yeah holy [ __ ] do I have
energy all day it's a little it's a
little too much really I think I feel
like I have too much energy right I
could use some of that energy really
yeah I could do what are you what are
you doing at night living oh you do
drink at night
yeah you don't me I don't drink you
don't drink when it wins let's are you
sleeping enough uh yeah I mean last
night fell asleep at 9 p.m. okay
goodnight hours asleep woke up at 5 a.m.
are you waking up on your owner you is
an alarm waking your son weeks yeah
that's right are you wet I usually wake
up on my own are you waiting for them
okay so you have to wake up in the
middle of a dream no not really
okay it's very rare I dream I did I
remember I dream last night
there is cuz my son it was late at night
so the the me give the pre story this so
like four weeks ago there's some package
being dropped off our house in a house
there it's a security gate knife to be
buzzed and anyone comes in and out is on
camera there's all these cameras now
so we buzz this guy and he comes in
drops the package off and he leaves and
then my son was over there playing and
whoever it was looked into the window
and my saw my son my son freaked out was
like pop out run towards mom he's like
ah I'm pointing I'm looking and we don't
see anything then we see some guy with a
backpack like walking across anyway
scared him then last night it was like
late and we're like I don't know he's
watching Transylvania 3 or some [ __ ] you
know I'm not that scary but he's two and
a half and then he was scared again he
was super scared again okay it's strange
Tess furious I'm intelligence yeah I
forget what forget where we're going
with a story
ah terrible story but luckily and always
no energy
Oh Oh energy but sleep yeah you get
usually you get you wake up with your
Center 5 we're gonna still at 5 I took
him up he was scared
oh my dream because he was talking about
he's muchacho right he speaks goddamn
Spanish he gets a muchacho a muchacho
and my dream was dreaming if there's a
muchacho but it was Batman and we was
like a scary Batman you remember and you
weren't Batman we in the first one the
is it the Dark Knight we need that guy
blows that stuff in his face he turns
that like [ __ ] real scary Batman it
was that Batman we're like fighting by
could like grab his stupid official like
rubber mask yeah it's a weird dress it
dreams about money then I [ __ ] them
why I had to change about making money
last night really that means money is on
your mind it's on my mind money's on my
mind wine on your money money on your
life by the markets to turn the [ __ ] I'm
like holy [ __ ] hold on it's fine but
it's very interesting my loner some dude
what's going on yeah I think since I
stopped this is so [ __ ] LA since Isis
I can't it might help somebody I'm like
a hot yoga shop to eat and goddamn read
me change era yoga chick dairy red meat
and [ __ ] and alcohol during the week
you're also older no gluten like maybe
it's time to write but buddy [ __ ] no
way this this rise has been a gift
because my surprise is a clear way to
look at it so I'll clear it up and I and
I figured out how to eat is it all gone
pretty much house shooting me going good
one wallet when will school here do you
know probably after we shoot the
thirteenth episode how many do you shoot
13 13 though once you then I got seven
months off and once you wrap then
they're gonna air it yeah one thing I
wrap in them so how many weird that I
want to get back on the road how many
weeks is that no it was the roads a
love/hate thing when I'm on it oh my god
man I want to get home then I'm home for
a little too long I gotta get back you
look 12 years I've been doing it and I
took a the first time I've ever taken a
break and I'm like it's gonna be good
for you though come with new [ __ ] yeah
100%
haven't come haven't written joke one
well you've been freaking doing the
other game I don't think I don't know if
you can do both some guys do but
it's gonna be tough are you event out
with your show it's not like you're just
like I mean every scene brother always
seen it's getting tough at night to
freakin come up with new [ __ ] stand up
yes free your mind but if I said it I
set an alarm I'll set an alarm for 23
minutes 25 minutes a weird number and I
don't do anything but think but yeah did
you focus on that yeah so what so when
will the first one here you think you
shouldn't it's midseason replacement so
it was supposed to be like maybe
November even I don't know we'll see
so America has to watch it maybe
November something like that something
like that because then Roseanne's come
back right because they're Rosanna
Brogan today I'm excited that he's
Rosanna coming back is she gonna be on
the show they're off the Conner but
there's Conor's are back so they killed
Rosanna well that too
I'm sure the first episode would be huge
yes after they had a 44 million or
something like that the first it's like
the biggest show ah [ __ ] ah she [ __ ]
it up God everybody wanted that show
back she's crazy but I would assume it
does well the first has to be like crazy
good because they want to know what the
hell happens how they brought back like
you're a lot of the writers quit because
they didn't want to be Rosanna it's
those toxic it's like Whitney and like a
la the big-time writers they just didn't
like her they I don't know if it's why
wouldn't he quit but I'm just saying
like well you have the original creators
in like writers they brought on for the
the new Roseanne have left so I wonder
if it's the Connors now that they're
back well you and I were talking about
whether or not like it she says she
swear she did another woman was black
which I can believe I don't care about
that it was it but but at the end of the
day it's still a mean thing to do right
isn't it like yeah I think she it's a
pastor like oh she's crazy mental
disorders whatever but
racist is racist you look at her
previous tweet she like she's kind of
had a thing of this and when they signed
her up to do this show on ABC they asked
her not not to be on social media
because they know was a risk with her
side she was always saying crazy [ __ ]
it's like with uh Brett Kavanaugh that
this guy right like me and my brother
were talking about this like who's Brett
Kavanaugh let's say if we were like dude
he's 18 let's say did receptor he's 18
17 he didn't rape it was a well a little
bit different yeah but did there was
just need some sexual harassment sexual
assault
everybody said to me that they just say
but let's just say there's some sexual
assault there even at sixteen thirteen I
have no friends I never not even close
at sixteen or seventeen there's any
sexual assault ever like not even like
well do you all realize what never yeah
never never my 35 years yeah has ever
been not even close
yeah so for him to be Supreme Court
justice it's a little dicey yeah it's a
little in people like dude he was 17
doesn't get free pass here's my if
that's a man tell you seventeen it's
gonna be we listen not that you should
be banned for your entire life should be
Supreme Court justice
well my say is this I actually
personally as crazy as if kristinb lazy
for it seems a little off right she
seems to me lady she seems a little
crazy
does she seems I'll tell you this I'll
tell you this I believe her and this is
why I believe her right do like and it
doesn't matter because there's no
corroborating evidence but but I will
say this about the research psychologist
at Stanford University yeah I'm sure
she's smart smart yes I'm sure she is
she didn't want to do this like she
didn't want to come out and she was
obviously shrinking unlike if she had
been somebody had been trying to you
know breaking them [ __ ] and I agree
if it was like this one didn't want to
do this right so she told her husband
six years before and I actually talked
about it in therapy and she told some
people sue she's been kind of talking
about this for six years from what I
understand this kid Brett Kavanaugh came
in he was 17 or whatever stumbling drunk
I think from what I understand he got on
top of her somebody turned the music up
and then she started to scream and he
covered her mouth well and then but they
did so he was on top of her and then
somebody jumped on both of them and they
all fell off okay and she did mention
the three other people that were in the
room and actually Brett Kavanaugh in his
weird diary because he got the diary has
those people in that time frame going
out for skis for brewskis so what so so
to me I'm left with a real
really complicated like if I'm a senator
this is how I look at it I go I do
believe her I believe that that kid at
17 I went to college down there I knew
Georgetown Prep kids they're pretty
entitled you know and this kid grew up
in a bubble bred Calvin I grew up in a
bubble make no mistake
okay he brought you up in a bowl yeah so
whether or not he did that when he was
17 he was stumbling drunk maybe he was
blacked out who the [ __ ] knows I don't
know we obviously drank to excess all
the time we know that here's my question
it's a question are we we have to be are
we willing now to say what you did as an
adolescent you did a bad thing as an
adolescent whether it was kill somebody
rape somebody if he's actually so
gorgeous on sexual assault somebody
stomped somebody into the ground and a
bar fight whatever is we we know that in
our court of laws we seal a juveniles
record for that reason I would then
reasonably steal a juveniles record I
think up until they're 18 depending on
the state is because we know that a 17
year old 16 year old 15 year olds brain
is different it's still developing it's
different even 17 and 18 you still know
rape and sexual assault so here's here's
what I'm 17 that didn't cross well
here's my here's my caveat here's my
caveat here's my caveat to please
advocate we also know that 17 sometimes
17 and 18 years were tried as adults for
that exact reason yeah like you knew
that [ __ ] you were doing as bad the
question that again the question becomes
how long do you penalize them well no
it's not even that it's it my thing is
that if you if there's any history of it
you can't hold a position of the Supreme
Court job I said it well yeah yeah you
should like listen you shouldn't you can
do some other job sure but you should be
a school counselor right you shouldn't
be a Supreme Court but let me ask you
this gonna be a third bit as a as a
senator you have to vote yea or nay
ready somebody comes up and they say as
compelling as her testimony may be to
you there's still no evidence and for me
his word against three right so for me
what I do is I go see the problem is
we're talking about methodology here is
right but here's the other problem I
have he wouldn't do the lie-detector
test right he was like uh no she she did
a lie-detector test
she took a lot he wouldn't I don't know
I don't know first of all those are not
I know that
but just the fact you don't even do it
but but but what I'm saying is that what
I'm saying is that again even that even
all that stuff isn't you know and that's
this dispute about her coaching somebody
mikemaya issue is this I found myself
going even though I may believe her if I
had to vote yay or nay
I have to go on so III the precedent has
to be if you're gonna accuse somebody we
have to have some evidence film evidence
that's what I that's what I'm saying and
if you don't then it's open season for
anybody on the left of the right to be
attacked it has nothing to do with him I
don't know about his politics I don't
really think I think he's probably
according to such some people that his
voting record is not very conservative
but he seems to be a very partisan guy
right he seems to be Republican Joe so
you know I don't try I try not to get
into that I'm just looking at it myself
go and be and I've seen a long time
sexiest he's hideous that's funny he was
younger I don't know yeah I don't know
man I found myself going and you got a
tweet on I feel bad for some you've got
to have some corroborating evidence
I agree I just don't like that there's
any of this darkness swirling around
your Supreme Court justice you know I'm
saying like well I don't want that give
me look I mean at the end of the day you
know she did come forward cuz she said
it was her civic duty I mean it you know
I don't know I I have no problem
believing that the guy used to get drunk
and behave like an [ __ ] I mean no it
seems like you know it seems like he I
like bear I still like he was he was a
blackout drunk yeah why'd he do that
it's so funny like this beer it's so
great when he did that's the best part
of the thing I watched every second I
was like look at that it's so old school
what we're doing just oh you know if you
take our life you take xanax if you take
xanax it can completely negate it keeps
you like totally calm they're a lot of
ways to try that be
I know try it what do you mean try it
and see if that works 100% of the time
if I'm taking a lie detector test yeah
but apparently it does yeah I don't know
I've been telling the truth and
stuff that's well recordings because
you're lying I was like no I'm not but
I'm a wiggler yeah you know Wiggly I
don't know they are apparently
lie-detector tests are pretty accurate
though the ones you guys took was that
legit
I don't not really a lady seemed a
little sketchy yeah okay she was kind of
getting on her nerves a while ago yeah
she wasn't good I was like what do you
do I teach yoga as little dicey little
dicey yeah I did meet a guy who was on
his way he was in court and he had a
lie-detector test and I talked to him I
got all they work me look amigas they
work they work he said oj simpson took
one like privately before they started
the the trial in the kardashian the you
know the the dad kardashian was there
and saw it and they're like oh we can't
we can't show this thing cause so if
it's your lawyer if you have a good
lawyer your lawyer will tell we'll come
up with the questions for the person so
if it did so remember a lie-detector
test will be set up by a lawyer and the
questions being asked are so this is
fitting yeah so a lot there's a lot of
reasons how can you did you murder
Nicole Simpson he's old but yeah but my
buddy who's a criminal defense lawyer
Brad he said there's a thousand ways
where you manipulating you can take off
and the first question they would ask
you a prosecutor which they didn't ask
Christine [ __ ] are you first are you
on drugs or alcohol now you got any
drugs now and second of all when you
took a lot of types of tests were you
under the influence of any kind of a
barbiturate opiate so now they didn't
ask that this but now they do yeah
that's what you always ask that that's a
that's a standard question so there were
a lot of questions well I heard
Psychopaths can pass it yes well some of
them if you're taking lie detector test
oh I would love to know one I would like
a real light you want up or get a real
one or do you love dick there you go
this is all don't get that same girl
then get a real it you should get a real
weed find out so many questions that'll
be fun it'd be a good idea film it I
don't know where you get a real one from
like I can't trust it sure people write
in under this now
this is like a part-time job can take
him serious
I was doing when I was hit
listen I don't answer this guy this is
[ __ ] man
yeah man that's it that says that's a
moment in American history of this
Cavanaugh thing man
it has divided the country at least
Kanye West is know the White House today
is he he was yeah he was right yeah the
other time at Chicago though I mean he
knows cago but politics I'm not sure he
was there for that modern music act too
but he was late Kanye West was late yeah
the White House yeah for the modern
music act when Bill Clinton when Trump
signed the modern music act the new one
he was supposed to be there but he's got
yeah a little bit late what's the new
modern music Act what is it you know
when um like straight for the internet
before the internet came there's certain
rules and regulations on how people get
paid if you're an artist producer
songwriter that kind of went out the
window with streaming because it's like
well let's not so Vader they're putting
backorder into it so the people that
made the music created it are getting
the money they deserve now cuz streaming
cuz now the other kind of crude right so
it's it there's more like there's more
structure now but there will be more
structure now that's cool that's really
good for musicians and artists that's
really good songwriters because before
they just felt bloated instruments like
whatever they're just kidding there's
just too many different ways that
they're getting they're not getting
their money you know this is more
streamlined now to be streamlined we're
next to actors and next tallest I mean
it's gonna it's good 10-year do you mean
in 10 years you know you're there's so
much content out there and so easy to
get it for free that it's gonna be where
we'll be facing the same thing musicians
are I don't think so because there's
Netflix there's you know there's
streaming services but you have to pay
for that yeah you know well I think that
then you're always gonna what would you
say is such a glut that wonder yeah a
glut meaning there's so many look how
many shows his Netflix have on now no is
it 700 I think it might be sunny but if
you look at everything though I mean
that's you look at all but there's more
there's more opportunity now for actors
commander 30 TV shows and 6750 five
movies that's a lot how many new TV
shows
but don't [ __ ] it's a good thing B has
never been more opportunity to work for
hundred percent there's never been more
availability for comics to get their
specials out there's more because before
is HBO Comedy Central right
yes that's it yeah and the Showtime a
couple of there's a few and there was
just the big big dogs they have Netflix
Amazon Hulu Facebook is doing content
now yet YouTube when you're gonna sell a
show you have 25 outlets to sell it to
yeah it's because before if a trio is
like now we're all good
you're like ah [ __ ] man yeah and there's
no internet there's nothing now if you
have a big enough falling you could go
you just release it on your own on
YouTube there's ways to get the material
out there one before it's just kind of
correct put away correct I think it's a
good thing so do i I think it of course
it is it's never been a better time for
an actor for a writer for a director in
a lot of ways but you said do you think
everyone you're gonna be the same as me
I think what's gonna happen well first
certainly for actors I think will happen
there's so many different TV shows and I
think then there's so many actors and so
I think what happens it always is look
if it's already happen in movies it's
already happen in movies but what they
figured out was back in the day you'd
make if you were just a character actor
your contract you can make three four
hundred grand for a movie and they pay
it for it because you were a good actor
now they just go you're getting scale
and scale is very little money yeah
you'd say no and they'd say it's like
being a fighter they're like we got
another actor in the wings we got ten
more and they're good so what were you
saying and this is happening to even
actors you know so there's one person
who makes the money so I was always
waiting for that to happen I was always
like as a capitalist and a free market
guy I was like this would make this
would make sense why are you paying me I
know I was making some crazy amount of
money on a TV show one time I was like
oh I just can't be I was like I don't
know if they know this but I would do
this for almost for free yeah you know
but they're you know so well the good
thing as more people are working though
yeah
but then you know I agree I have to be
understand never never a better time for
a night to be an actor or an artist yeah
you can make a living agree
and and you can get you know and there
are other ways to what like like on
YouTube or what even your special what
you may not make money on your special
but you're gonna sell tickets live look
at podcasting like nobody on my TV show
could believe how much like how well we
do on this podcast I didn't tell exact
words
oh yeah and and school then I was they
were like what you can make money on a
podcast I was like hi you can release
the document really mm yeah super late
to the party everybody's late to that
party so they're oh it's a terrible
movie on Netflix what I told you what it
was chin what was it a terrible movie
there's oh that the someone recommended
it to you it was so bad I forgot the
name I think some good movie
recommendations like scary movies people
offend them but this one was [ __ ]
terrible
you gotta watch the Korean one man I'm
telling you I know I just got a try Joe
Hart yeah you've told you stories for
several times yeah if you ever watch it
no that's too old and he hasn't seen old
boy yet right you talked about although
that's a great movie you haven't seen
you know oh boy old boy you've got to
see that that's the one definitely have
to watch it made a while ago it's really
redid it but don't watch the American
don't watch an American version even
though that's Josh Brolin it doesn't
work I love the Korean version yeah how
old is it doesn't matter it's not that
old
it's not that old I'd say it's pretty
old 2003 that's not too bad it's such a
good movie it's it's you don't know
don't read into it don't like don't
watch anything about it just watch the
movie without yeah you see the trailer
dude no okay but so does it 87% oh this
movie like everything salting but it but
it's not a scary movie it is
there's scary elements it's just a great
freaking movie there's so many elements
to that you're gonna freak out about
well now you guys have hyped it up too
much you've told me too much alright
watch this real quick yeah
that Jackie Chan no I said is this such
a good singer he's such a good actor too
he's falling down a lot huh it's also a
comedy though there's a lot there's so
many good parts - yeah I have to watch
this movie again so Josh Brolin did a
remake get it yeah but it's not good
whatever you do a cream movie and an
American remake you know it's great
everything is just different yeah but
you know if the Americans are going to
do it it's a great movie yeah it's like
we blew me away
I love this Marilyn Manson sounds like
he up
Korea has taken over bro so good summer
- too much for me though the movies yeah
but there's some great Korean filmmakers
and great Korean actors oh this is the
best scene
[Music]
except choi ji-hae ratings holiday
everyone loves it when they watch dude
I'll tell you the worst movie and it
came from a recommendation on boys TV
blue-eyed Stevie yummy $4.99 I heard it
was bad and we watched the trailer in
here and I thought that looks [ __ ]
terrible and me and [ __ ] I know it is
the gaudy movies gonna say it's so bad
really
it's and that you know I love mafia
movie I love the John Gotti stories and
all that stuff it's so bad it's Z worst
movie I've seen they have in common for
20 years did here I show my love
yep we got him in here I like that awful
we had him in here feel like we have do
we have Kevin Connolly in there totally
not when I was here who I like is a
great guy not directing brightest thing
maybe a fry that maybe it's yeah he
directed it John Travolta I love John
he's so bad in this really Oh God
you drunk Walter usually doesn't miss
moving so I dude 30 minutes 35 minutes
into it I looked at my girl and she goes
oh my god it's the worst thing we've
ever seen she goes I just can't like wow
I take I take Steve Eagar what the [ __ ]
man is I like oh my god damn it who's
boss
god it's so like if you were trying to
make a shittier movie be tough Wow it
was it the way it looked like even the
way to show them that Lily everything we
like name some the dialogue be she
acting don't the story written by
somebody who probably didn't know the
crime world or something was that was I
think it's based off a book i god it was
bad about that if the three of us wrote
a god a movie and I decide to shoot it
next month this this is what I expect my
grandmother here said is it trouble
Travolta Travolta I loved John Travolta
John Travolta God it was bad though so
it's good movie though that that movie
uh Littlefoot
Littlefoot yeah
it has watch as a bunch of kiddo
dinosaur moving small foot sorry that's
Land Before Time Littlefoot was the main
character that's Moffatt Triceratops
yeah oh gee a movie oh it looks like the
dude from Disney Lion Matterhorn oh yeah
he does
is that right still there I get to take
master Disneyland tomorrow you do I
think this is gonna always be than it is
the Halloween nights so they you got it
they shut down the park unless you have
a special take it and so the kids can
trick-or-treat and have all that
villains from Disney it's cute but from
like 7:00 to 10:00 p.m. so that's a long
it's a bit of a beast is there a line or
there's lines but it's let wait less
people both parks shut down okay and
have to have the stretch ticket we got
like six months ago
Wow because we wanted last year last
year we're around the same time and
they're like you gotta leave now like
why like it's Disney Halloween night Wow
oh the Matterhorn Steel's going down
yeah probably forever solid ride and
they made the Thunder Mountain one
better to like a little changes many
years ago uh Thunder Mountain well that
now their hottest like type of car
rollercoasters cars all cars
nothing's legit super fun as fun I went
on that one will you don't go anywhere
but the screen is the cars moving in the
screen is coming soon since I got sick I
had to close my eyes oh yeah motion
sickness the cars just moving you're not
going anywhere
the cars on these hydraulics blew them
and then the screen windows my daughter
was I gotta [ __ ] you not sick watching
this with us tell me what to Disney
lynchin it's been a while ma'am maybe
like three or four years ago we would go
every Christmas you don't want it's like
Christmas um no just a bunch of friends
all right you guys don't have fun there
it's fun it's fun we have kids like is a
grown man you're gonna yeah
get a six flag challenge in China in the
middle of August like I was I think it's
great
pop a shop get to the town in tonight
pop it to shop this cool I'm seeing a
while on that seat wrap I don't you ever
invite me out when you're with your dad
I don't know he doesn't like you dude
I'm just kidding no no I barely hear
he's in for [ __ ] two days out he's in
Spain they've been traveling a ton of
spring he's gonna Vietnam next month
that's cool thought my nerves
he he he and his wife yeah and he really
digs her they've been the other forever
I hope he takes it yeah yeah but I mean
they travel it's great ah maybe I'll get
the traveling bug you me but stone I
just don't have it either buddy
I guess cuz I traveled so much as a kid
I just don't snuff they're like my dad
I'm sure I'll hear for it the next two
days all his travels and the pictures
and stuff like that and the food and I
just it doesn't entice me to go I have
no desire I mean either you know the
cultures and I just don't care now I'm
sure it's great right the long flight
right nothing your dad's are both
retired I'm still hurt my dad's not
still works it works
Owens own business makes its own
schedule but hmm here's some current
chin
are you you like to travel chin I didn't
really care about that much but after we
travel to Dublin and London all those
places I got the bug reel and of course
yeah Australia we didn't get to see [ __ ]
lot of stuff we covered was Melbourne
felt like guys actually someone we had
time to do stuff England felt like
you've been doing it at York have you
been data
no no really Florence Rome it's
beautiful that's great aful
those are the food everything ever
places I mean truly yeah it's like I'm
going on vacation in February Lawrence
we're on February I mean look at it
look at that that's Florence enjoy that
look at that come on I do I know it
looks great there's no desire like I got
again a plane and get there but there
that place is magical it's just walking
around and eating at the restaurant
I mean it's just impossible it's
impossible I want to rent an apartment
there right now Italian what else you
got you wear scarves did you do that
easily doors jackets and scarves and I
want to get cold in Italy was the
weather like I mean it's it's it's
temperate but it gets a little cold but
no nothing like la I think right
have you been to Vienna I've never been
to Vienna hmm that is a place that was
untouched by the war
so Vienna is still a jewel yeah I kind
of only go to Europe remember with her
rush is pretty cool Russia you can get
some I've been a Russian long time yeah
st. Petersburg but but but Vienna is is
not was not decimated by World War two
and remember most of Europe was leveled
in World War two I mean leveled by bombs
Dresden looked like the surface of the
Moon for sure a real problem no but it
was but it's true Greece was just saying
everything was real dude have you seen
before sunrise with Ethan Hawke Julie
Delpy you'll want to go to a VA and
after watching that no really yeah it's
a good movie - it's all dialogue which
I'm sure you love all right what are you
good all right first what is this I know
you guys have heard this already a plane
being evacuated because a woman had a
you know one of those pets that help you
out with anxiety and everything else
yeah what's it called again
I mean it's emotional social support and
shittim squirrel
why would people afraid of it it's
considered a road is it a rodent so was
the rodent flipping out no it was in its
own little carrying case yeah people
were flipping out well she's kind of
messed up too because they say she can't
bring it on board she has to leave and
that she would've refused to leave so
everyone else had to do board the plane
but so she brought on board and the lady
like the flight attendant I was like
well ma'am can have a squirrel on the
playa and it passed TSA checkpoint cuz I
guess they're not the ones that have to
stop you and also TSA the worst like oh
we get the cat very cool carry on it's
up to the my question is why a dog and
not a squirrel squirrels get a bet well
you know II just had mini horses I've
heard many horses maybe God but
hilarious
dude I would be irate if some [ __ ]
brought her stupid squirrel on the plane
and we wouldn't get out I mean you want
to see her
yes misses her again she uh let the
squirrel that [ __ ] cage him attack
people's face it this girls are feisty
dude
squirrels actually you don't get the bad
rap is the rat is there any diamonds
getting the saran wrap not though these
have a fancy tail Don's there she is
she's flipping people off
[Applause]
[Music]
and she yelled out before home when she
was getting carried out she's like I'm
the crazy woman I'm the crazy one in the
everyone off however picked this up and
she was on a new state and loves the
[ __ ] of that squirrel it's probably
single a young old or no she's buried
with the daughter okay okay kill how
good how good-looking is now he's lost
weight yeah a handsome son of Oishi
pride she's just uh older oh wow you
know what he's cute yeah okay see a
sugar glider Oh what is he a sugar
glider squirrel big difference no your
lives are cute like flying squirrel nuts
yeah they're cute no those are big this
is a real no some actual squirrels are
big uns you know you ever seen a sugar
glider no you can buy sugar gliders I
ate at the pet store yeah yeah yeah
they're tiny yeah at friends different
animals little sugar gliders [ __ ] how
to straight-up squirrel like from your
backyard yeah know this like come on
it's a sugar glider songs you it's cute
right come on I'll let that thing on the
[ __ ] plane huh Co thing you [ __ ]
fly around that sugar glider my friend
used to hunt him and eat him said
they're good actual squirrel yeah she
she's had a regular [ __ ] normal Park
squirrel as a friend yeah whatever
there's New York City we used to have to
do an activity so you have to do an
activity and act it and this kid is a
hillbilly came into our school and put a
dead frozen squirrel on the ground he
was gonna skin it and all the city boys
I just go
go this guy's I can't just go and I was
like you [ __ ] loser
you [ __ ] and then my teacher goes
alright you go I'm annoyed at you as he
was leaving annoying you for the guy
with the I know that both of you both II
do think you squirrel though let's
finish this video quick this is another
good part so it is a designated portion
of this airline he's just yes he could
you know chris cooley know what she's a
crazy squirrel crazy crazy cat lady she
said hold my beer crazy squirrely it's
right it's crazy scrolling I want to
find crazy raccoon man yeah I'll be
those I got a crazy snake people crazy
everything crazy squirrel though
tarantulas catch in um this did you
watch Australia it for the trailer okay
you saw my camera shirt it's so good I
feel like it's gonna suck he looks like
death Jeremy now it looks like they're
trying to for free handers and Brendan
Dassey
[Music]
so sometimes it feels like you want to
cry but you can't Billy's making Bank
then off Netflix right where's the money
going to Brendan Dassey city's
WrestleMania pay-per-view I have one
goal and that's to overturn the
conviction of Steven Avery I'll watch it
I want you to there's no way to be as
fun as the first one so Brendan thinks
if I tell them what they want to hear
[Music]
I'm gonna go home little dumbass mom
dude okay but this case is solid if he's
guilty I'll fail she's a badass
super badass so obviously you have to
make it fun for the documentary make it
all controversy and stuff but they say
he's a bad dude I just thought around
like the bad neighborhood in that
community yeah I was known for came
there I get no [ __ ] he did it of course
he'd like I guess he's had some troubled
past their way of course well they
talked about that in the first one so
yeah but that dude do you think he's
innocent right that burnin dude like
he's just as any of that I think he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I don't think he did
it but he definitely had something to do
with he's aware of it he's awfully you
know he could be coaxed into doing
something for it
you talked him into anything I mean I
talked him in the [ __ ] peeling his
face off such a baby
I hate those name's Brendan but whatever
yeah well he's actually slow yes maybe
they don't know that for sure I know
he's always been his IQ it's very very
low and I think it's the family I know
he's got he's a slow child I don't think
so no just looking at rings out but he
had he was in special education I don't
think he's a regular school aid look a
mom promised use before I came in from
does he have a learning disability and a
DD doesn't count
no he does Brendan Dassey learning
disability handles intellectual
disability there's a big problem with
branch deaf sees low IQ yeah on learning
hold on Jesse didn't know what he was
doing because he's he as one lawyer said
learning disabled sixty notes so what's
r and brendan dassey's IQ how much does
a factor in this let's break down the
timeline don't need to keep scrolling
down versus being charitable seventy
that's
fourth grade low he's at a fourth grade
level yeah he definitely looks sloven
know he had mental disability find me
I've never seen it it's like a murder
thank you is 70 that's a fourth-grade
level I see but see fourth grade reading
level like Floyd maybe my reading fourth
grade level I promise you they're very
can't it's not a code so you can't even
if you wanted to read more I have a
fifth grader and I can promise you
that's tough ya know can't be killing
people what else you got gin on one side
ones that drop by the way I could I need
something right now when's this drop its
it'll burn I don't drop so much right
his fight world where Frank willow went
all over the world and went to different
gyms Senegal a whole bunch people watch
it supposed to be amazing
my brim is full on the fight world I'm a
brim that's true this is more like the
way Anthony Bourdain looks at food it's
not just about fighting the people at
fight 25th of September so it's already
out no there's no way it's out it's not
out I'll tell you chest out did you type
in making murder to Netflix now it's
25th of September yeah it's out it's
been released on the night ah I'm [ __ ]
what's your reading level gentlemen
what's why is this so difficult in this
room I said October 19th Dean I did
earlier but then I saw those sober 19th
what's today next week something far
[ __ ] mother [ __ ] I don't see these
boys fry just kidding huh let's see what
happens
go on all right [ __ ] um Dwayne Johnson
the rock he's getting a little bit of
backlash for playing a folk hero that's
actually that's supposed to be
african-american he is has I heard of
John Henry he is his part
african-american he's getting bad luck
to be all the like the community and let
how much backlash a few Twitter trolls
byph you and me is happy [ __ ] off it's
quite a few yeah but this is all Twitter
[ __ ] I'm not even gonna address it okay
has the studio or anything say anything
no so you have to check your family tree
before you do anything can i play can i
play a Swede if the backlash is also I
think mainly pointed out the fact that
he never takes he never considered
himself African
American before you didn't you didn't
consider self a black eye and then since
this thing came along he's kind of you
so he's Samoan and black yeah okay so
what what is he not minority enough I
don't understand
no I don't they want like a straight-up
black guy yeah straight-up black on it
would go down is that the trailer for
right there yeah it's really really
short let me see a teaser now it's gonna
be a little if he's like oh damn yo I'm
John man like he starts talking all
ghetto we don't want that but it was a
rock wouldn't do that
that's it and people are upset huh what
are you gonna do most of them just black
people well it's like it's like remember
when Matt Damon played I think you're
supposed to play well I do but there's
another movie there's a whole thing
about your hands there certain actors
dealing with this now like if you're not
part of the same tribe you have to get
permission like what the [ __ ] didn't
talk about guys you know I mean no they
may have these people might have an
argument if it was Bryan Callen playing
John is that why yeah I mean there I can
I'm supposed to be like what their no
black actors that can play this sure
so yeah the argument I saw the most was
he didn't identify as a black man until
until now that's what they're getting
upset so should be abrasive beforehand
my feelings not black enough for them is
the only thing to I think but it's
making Harvey Weinstein Weinstein one of
the charges was dismissed one woman and
it's because the the lead detective in
charge he excluded some information that
she said to him which means she actually
got paid to suck him off oral sex to get
you know a role in a movie do we know
who this is yeah we know who the woman
is yeah who is it who's paid her for a
[ __ ]
Evans Lucia Evans go ahead and google
her first you know see what's going on
she does look a little she sucked them
off for like a lead role over time
Oh dirt it's for money and then sucked
him off for a role in movie so she
admitted this to the cops detective but
he took my pick on the damages for me
let me just see what kind of Harvey
Weinstein's ever she's a very sexy woman
I'll tell you that he is she's a chin on
her and she's uh that does complicate
the case I mean yes she's it does
complicate it so that's a big win for
him so he was like suck me off you're me
Catwoman - so she consented found that
there are a lot of women I think a lot
of the Hollywood that have done what
they lot of guys and girls who do with
that that's all the way around a lot of
sex for sale so so that one that case is
dismissed nice but weird that I'm
attracted to her is it weird that I
appreciate her hustle look at this
you're weird I want to slide on her dams
and offer a role on fighting the kid now
yeah yeah well that one's a little that
one's cool husband she's very pretty
lady
yeah I'm sure how gornstein wasn't just
asking warlocks to suck them off trying
to be in Superman seven you better suck
me off right here's money won't agree
with it but hey Arendt lettuce yeah this
happens on the daily in Hollywood what's
happening as we speak
that's right it always has and I think
it always will when I was a young boy if
someone said hey you want to make the
Buffalo Bills you got to jack the head
coach off bragging the jack him up and
Jack him off right that's right all
right um this is Katz
Summa Katz Kern events and this is in
Turkey a pizza shop employee is facing
up to 18 years in prison because he is
accused of spitting on the pizza that he
delivered if you don't want a large
prison for how like you just did it once
yeah but so he thought that he was
saying that one of his colleagues
delivered to that place before and the
guy's very picky about his his pizza so
when he was delivering it he just
checked the box to see if everything was
in order and I'll show you the video
right now you guys can judge me saying
he just spit on it he said he didn't
spit on it yeah I'm a pizza expert from
here
so he's has his phone out checking it
yeah I think he's been on there bro yeah
I'm filming it blends with he's
definitely he's definitely like these
stickers tongue out looks like he's
trying to take a picture of himself with
the pizza I know you spit out and put
his tongue out and then watch out there
like that looks like you spent it well
this is it I'm not Sherlock Holmes but
then Robson he definitely spit on the
pizza 18 years
that's not excessive though is it though
you spit on my Domino's bro what you
doing time 18 years no Turkish person is
up terrific so [ __ ] up yeah give him a
month and he'll catch off his pinky off
friend Juba talk about a hot fresh pizza
I don't chop it's not chopped limbs off
chop his pinky off no you're really hard
do it again well I'm sure he won't just
you know let him get away with a little
bit he starts ticking crazy bread up his
[ __ ] man what's going on here
all right do you guys know who Terrence
J is sure do he's a whole second part
yep he's uh he was on e for a long time
and now he's on power he left
Ian went to power that girl is very
attractive does she need a job that's
his girl and that's his car to McLaren
well there's at 12:30 and then midnight
um in Studio City it crashed and
witnesses said that she was driving and
he was in the passenger seat and they
they booked it they took off that's Mars
probably my thunder them for most likely
yeah
so no one got hurt I mean they haven't
talked to the police yet okay so anyhow
that very very expensive MacLaren's
crashed he's trying to get it back
MacLaren's a great car that's not gonna
be cheap no canady
I'm surprised you can even be salvaged
by not I heard it's a yes it's done
that's game over yeah but I mean the
story here is that he's not coughing up
they're not coughing up to what they did
so they could possibly get in trouble
with the pours AJ I was I hit my head I
was just Orion and I ran home that's the
then they can't prove otherwise I think
history has shown if you're drinking and
you crash to get Runnels you probably
should run away to run away it's the
reality yeah hate to say it but man what
are what they're gonna do cuz they I'm
sure they can prove they're in the car
right unless like nope someone stole it
bro he could why didn't you report
that goes to the trash heap doesn't it
that car right there yeah cars [ __ ]
you can't there's some Salvage it are
your Salvage but maybe the back rim some
of the back vendors and stuff like that
but then no cars done man and [ __ ] up
that one no no that's another one that's
post more Jesus Christ postman gets but
someone hit him what's that car
300 400
uh yeah 350 400 that McClaren depend
what McLaren is more expensive
that's all say I didn't realize you
could afford that car what are the
famous on that be on that one three
grand a month no price six to seven
sixty seven thousand dollars a month how
much that car cost it depends which one
it is do do McLaren turn thirty thousand
no that's the base that one looks like
this six seventy do I bet yeah be it's a
720 so if he has a 720 looking at
$350,000 car for our thousand dollar car
if he bought it brand new you looking
about 475 right yes it's 10 grand a
month or something right yeah fairly
come between what you put down and also
if it's a lease no you don't those it
depends on what she drives you don't
want least those cars no cuz it's gonna
get get no miles right you know miles so
you can only put like 200 miles on a
[ __ ] year buy it so sell it and make
some of your money back yeah I'll hold
it then we'll make McLaren they're good
yeah they're decent better than
Bentley's yeah nothing in the Porsche
though God what the [ __ ] were they doing
where they crashed
I mean 12:30 at night it's pretty
obvious that well I'm not I don't know
but most out the jury mad at her though
crash my car girl Jesus Christ
mmm-hmm good for him what else you got
Jen
let's take a look that's not it
alright so this dude put up his wife on
eBay as a joke and the bids got up to
one hundred nineteen thousand people
wait but sell girlfriend mean she she
just sleeps with you for a night
actually I her you own her mm-hmm well
that's human trafficking how would
[ __ ] well he did as a joke and I don't
like when you look at eBay I think the
rule is if you bid and you don't pay and
the the person that's selling is one
trying to collect from you then you get
in trouble but this guy obviously is not
selling her so I think they just bid it
just for fun
damn and 24 hours later they removed the
the bid he's got a hundred nineteen
thousand dollars look at the policy sure
you can't sell human part body parts
first of all hey eBay why does that take
24 hours to notice someone selling their
girlfriend there's a lot going on but
there should be some sort of plan in
place they have actual people that look
at this especially on Facebook so you
have actual people that are looking at
every single post and they have to then
look at the nudity and take it down they
have to decide can we talk a little bit
about and don't sell your girlfriend
let's say let's say would you sell your
wife or girlfriend let's let's say let's
say offer you $150,000 one night okay
you fell my renting dude bro he's dumber
right it's your boy yeah now listen now
you if you're gonna let me here let's
say I'm gonna Street refer to as the fry
you let me Ferrari you get back put some
miles on it bro put some miles on it I
want you outside that exhaust system how
much time you know how much time you
need dude I get you drop her off at 9:00
p.m. peak about 9:00 a.m. 12 hours of my
wife a little talk with my wife and I go
look at me right now this is for the
kids college fund she would go where do
I sign anything goes now the tires a
little scuff the muffler out the back
give me a little wider paint jobs can be
a little scraped up gotta talk to a
couple bruises bro gotta talk to her
couple dents dings yeah gotta talk a
chat mouth would you why not no you
wouldn't no wait hold on not for a
hotting up for hundreds of thousands now
you talking about not 400 fuller for one
night
no not for him here's $200,000
latex-free no uh-huh
I'm good dude life's good and now you
want to offer me a few mil yeah well
everybody has been trying there there's
a price I'm
I'm a feeling I'll put my foot in the
water yeah now is it with your old
creepy ass because that changes things
what do you mean need 50 million I'm
your friend I know but your teeth bother
me come on man yeah think about that
every night hey man I'm your friend and
then when Tiger gets old I'm like you
know uncle Brian [ __ ] your mom huh no
till we bite this but that's a lot of
money dude this is Alif is million no I
like for MacLaren's with that okay what
if she get chin all right
this Elon Musk donated four hundred
eighty thousand dollars to Flint
Michigan schools quietly yeah I love
when they say that but you can't really
do anything these days be without it's
gonna get picked up I mean it's not like
you post on Twitter schools thinking
personally yeah yeah the administration
the district could fathom but look but
even you threw shade on them I'm sure
quietly well I'm sure I mean there is a
way to do it quietly yeah but he did for
$40,000 and so on we think gives off ah
yeah hey lis feel pretty cool elated
that who knows still pretty cool though
Cheers that's four in a thousand more
than anyone in this room donated
you know one time we donate 50 of us a
lady it acted like it's awful
you know what so I did I felt willing
that I was gonna donate to her you were
50 awkward's well I have other charities
I get whatever bro come on I get
stressed else you got chin this headline
looked pretty awesome right 123 missing
children recovered in one day Michigan's
sweep and then they also added that
they'll never stop looking for you [ __ ]
US Marshals 123 missing children
recovered in one day now what do you
guys think happened there honey was a
trafficking it was immigration no so
they did recover these children in a way
so I think three of them which they
recovered were possible sex trafficking
victims which is great that they got
them back but the majority of the kids
like the hundred 19 or whatever just
we're just they reported missing before
but they went back to their homes and
they they just
yes we still guard closed yeah and
that's Huff Post reporting I'd seen
through titties oh she looks really good
now she's providing pretty relaxing can
we talk a little bit about um khabib and
i do you have that on you're gonna miss
the khabib though crazy right
definitely what do you think I think
that this rematch is too valuable to not
to Dana and to UFC to not happen so I
think that they are going to do cubs
bidding in this case I don't I think
you're wrong
Riley yeah I think your honor I think
kabhi butt was already time about
leaving after this fight so now he's
like what the [ __ ] and kicked my boys
that I'm done yeah you don't care about
Fame money nice a fight nothing yeah
nothing oh he's done he's 27 no he's
walking away you did what he's gonna do
he doesn't like the politics and the way
the UFC is going you don't like the
disrespect and I think you know so many
fighters over the years have threatened
the UFC I'm gonna do this I'm do I'm not
fighting how many guys have we heard
well [ __ ] and I'm not fighting well if
you don't do this and really DFC is a
cool man Thea but now it's like you got
a guy he's like now you're [ __ ] with
my family my religion I'm out dude I'm
really out your sister but I think with
Dana and those guys if they go down this
road and you let the inmates run the
asylum
now and this is why you know there's a
whole nother can of worms talking about
the fighters union there's a fighter's
union these guys don't have to do this
you have a representative who's a
middleman who you can meet in the middle
so then Dana's ego doesn't get hurt and
khabib ziggo doesn't get hurt yes we
don't find out about this right union
would deal with all this there's not
that's not in place so now you have a
guy with khabib who's like cool man I'm
champ I won table now I'm not doing [ __ ]
and I should get my boy back in you're
still dealing with Conor McGregor who in
some ways does call shots because he's
such a draw and I think that the
temptation business-wise for Dana for
the UFC is to come up with a
space-saving way to get could be back in
with with this with his is his teammates
let me ask you this be could be you've
never been a draw ever ever ever so I'm
sure he's got a much bigger draw now
especially now he's like this
bad guy right and he off the
it has to fight Connor be a drawl let's
say cabbie goes away and then Connor
fights Tony Ferguson Nate Diaz who do
you think could make more money off of I
think probably I think at the end of the
day people forget about could be even a
lot of ways because I think I think also
have you seen the comments like I'll
post Li no I'm I'm Pro la off see I'm a
Connor dick Ryder I'm definitely like -
beep - yeah but if you look at like the
general consensus of especially in
America of Americans they really don't
give a [ __ ] about kabhi well now that's
not that's not me that's like it's it's
pretty I would actually say this I would
say that there's another school of
thought which would be the smart
decision would be to not fight Connor
against khabib again because there's a
very good chance it could be even a
worse mauling and I disagree I don't
know that you want to see that I don't
think kabhi was afraid of that left hand
anymore and I think could be puts even
more pressure and it's very very likely
that he'd be back on his back getting
punched in the face and I know but they
make so much money off that oh no what
I'm saying that what I'm saying is that
all Connor were saying is to risk
Connor getting beat up again he's not
gonna have many left dude you know what
I'm saying is maybe the better decision
is to fight him against Tony Ferguson
fight him against Nate Diaz because we
have short attention spans and then the
kabhi thing is something well he's not
he's not in anymore anyway Connor didn't
get a knock honor can be mad about it
but but you know I think you're right I
think at the end of the day I don't all
these Connors I'd go anywhere I mean
that's your poster boy even though he
lost they're like all right could be
cool man but I think Dana's going with
listen what his guy did we can't have
this and you know what could be did he's
spent so you know I don't know if we
strip her or not I'm hearing 18 or 12 to
18 months suspension Nevada so a day
mate i dude sokka Biebs openly
threatened us which I don't think is the
way to handle this because then you're
you're dealing with the UFC brass
they're like dude if we open up this
gate and guys realize they can get to a
certain level and then they own us where
it weren't trouble here well I I do i I
don't see doesn't keep the way they've
dealt with business before I don't see
them back and down I think we want to
see Connor talk and I think we want to
see him back it up and win I think Scott
is just so beloved that way
and awake honors a folk hero because
Connor is say what you will about that
[ __ ] dude he is so gutsy and he puts
it all on the line every time why
because he's just lost right beside his
life
yeah no nightmare and the next day he
calls Dana White and goes I wanted that
[ __ ] guy saying it how can you not
really saying it then and then these
morons these morons on Fox and he has
Pengo it's Connor of the X Ronda Rousey
I'm like you [ __ ] idiots
you common folk idiot here's the thing
Ronda lost twice didn't say face was a
poor losers took her ball and went home
yeah Connors lost before then came back
one could have fought anyone in the
world but fought that guy again at a
disadvantage 170 and be done yeah and
beat him in there and now we lost it
kebede yeah and then is the thing how
can he not respect that and also loses
he is everybody loses to khabib so again
it's like yes that that would make sense
that that was not that surprising I'll
tell you what I would do without what I
would do if I'm Connors management and
John Kent John his head coach on Rogan
said you know he wants to khabib fight
what I would do is hopefully this would
be the game plan of khabib gets spent
for a year to 18 months I've Connor
fight Nate Diaz for the 165 pound title
the the big nog world title the brand
new title I'm gonna fight Nate Diaz much
better matchup for him get that win and
then fight khabib off that layoff so
think a Beebe has a little bit of ring
rust and Congress more Act see you know
what I think ring Russ had a big fact in
Connors for sure you know what I think I
think he beats I think he should fight
Tony Ferguson 21st is a nightmare I
think he would beat Tony Ferguson here's
why Tony Ferguson as great a wrestler as
the other Tony Abreu at first and
Russell's defensively Tony Ferguson will
try to stand and bang with Conor
Tony Ferguson stands pretty Square up I
think Conor
I think Conor left hand of course it's a
tough fight but I think I think Conor
has a better chance of beating Tony
first and then of course he does it
could be for a second time I think I
think Tony has a better chance being
khabib maybe
Tony's a tough matchup for Kabir with
the pressure and his rest striking the
cardio the other thing I think if
does it not Tony out the car that could
be an issue Tony does not yes got higher
Oh another thing if Tony goes you know
what I know you can just knock me out so
I'm gonna wrestle for the first three
rounds and wear you out because I'm a
college wrestler all-american so I'm
gonna do that sell American oh yeah oh
no stun oh and by the way is jujitsu
nothing to shake a stick about either
striking is good too but I think you
know Connors the better striker but Tony
for the one who gets a little left out
in the dust air I would love to see Tony
vers Nate that's the fight Tony force
Nate Diaz is a [ __ ] war what I
feel but how about Nate Diaz his tweet
today goes here Dana I'll do your
favorite just release me cut me and sign
our uh sign frisky little boy let me go
I'll make this easy on you why does he
want to go you know he's gonna balance
her because I don't know what he wants
to do I don't know what he wants to do
some great fights for him I don't know
what I hope he comes back
hmm you guys got a lot too though he
always says stuff he always does it yeah
he always does it you know that's kind
of his thing I would love to see you
know you laughs you have to win the next
fight to give him a big win but inverse
Cubs amazing fight oh wow Nate versus
cabeza fighting could be it takes him in
ragdolls good chance I met you donates
you know when he's facing arrest give me
a little bit of trouble but again yeah I
think what happens to Nate is what what
what you need to go but but but I'm very
intrigued with Tony Ferguson being
tested by both could be been Connor I'd
really I would really like to see how
Tony Ferguson does against comment and
and yeah you're right that wrestling's a
factor I was surprised and I know people
fight the way dude I felt Conor walked
straight up and at khabees his photos
that was not the plan we told him like
I'm telling he was off him right he
everyone's go he gets his ass won nine
times that thing I disagree if that's a
Connor who's been in the ring and
there's no ring Russ and he's been
fighting MMA yeah because what he did in
boxing that you can't focus just on
boxing and then jump over to MMA
especially when you're fighting a guy
like khabib so I think it was a matter
of ring rust hmm I think's a matter for
having a hundred million dollars in the
bank and I think it was just a matter of
the match Oh
he felt he walked straight I don't know
what Connor that was I was like walking
straight in his corner like just don't
walk forward and what are you doing yeah
John Cavanaugh also goes we [ __ ] up in
camp because we were so defensive all we
did was counter wrestle like we took out
what Connor does well and we just worked
on it you know focus on kabhi me so how
would you so so with kabhi what would be
its own center walking straight up he's
gonna take you down okay so I'm gonna
get taken so learn to just stand up
learn how to stand up or what do you do
know like he did that first try he did
great not taking any damage if you take
him down you gotta make he held on it
was hanging up you gotta make him work
for the takedown
so he gets tired a noise he get tired
and then you pick your shots the third
fourth you got a plan to go in that
third fourth how do you how do you not
get fist their way - first of all not
stand that's straight up don't you avoid
that takedown
how did i up went to do that I can't
remember i cuenta of you know he avoided
it as the third and fourth runway on he
got tired
so the khabib shots were further out
Iaquinta also is a very big in a demon
wrestler I couldn't to decorate right
like yeah good wrestling yeah
so we're for for Conor I just the magic
wasn't there that night
listen there's no shame in it doesn't
like he's still one of the greatest he's
still [ __ ] - you're a monster
he fought [ __ ] Jose Aldo
Eddie Alvarez Floyd Mayweather max
Holloway Camacho no but I'm just saying
the short period I think could be yes
and then what's fight could be together
yo dude you can do so much other stuff
he is God regret later
Conor McGregor is a fighter through that
but I think his his though the way he
looked the the there's the mystic Mack
wasn't there's the lay off the ring rust
and the 100 million dollars in the bank
stuff man but the yo season a
predicament here because now you got a
guy in khabib who you can you can't go
listen just do this man you're gonna
make thirty million dollars you fight
connery match he goes I think I think
they'll find us a face-saving way for
everybody
we're coming able say you know me and
Danny talked we're friends I also
remember though could be doesn't run his
social media I'll leave his manager okay
so but I'm Kobe's not letting hit anyone
just blast whatever they want out so
this off something they discuss yeah I
don't know yeah I don't I think there's
you know the other thing that that's
super interesting and be
people need us especially now to an 18
his people go Dylan Danis said that he
that kabhi was a methine Muslim rat and
super racist and Dylan dance goes listen
that tape I did not say that I've never
I didn't say anything racist but people
are making it seem that way - okay what
khabees action right toward Dylan dance
because I just say anything of the sort
what did he was no less than the tape
just talking [ __ ] because there's no
racial term or slur ever in there right
but then these news outlets TMZ out of
course he's gonna just ask them when you
say something racial and Dylan I was
like whoa listen the tape I did not say
anything racist it still Dennis that
Bellator champion no he's new to my man
he's that one he's in Belgium yet yeah
yeah there's tape but you know collars
to beeps fans and there's people you
know can kind of paint those pictures
that you said this remember thing when
they Diaz people like oh you said you'd
this that never happened right you know
remember like that never happened yeah
but people want to paint a certain story
and they want to make sure that the fan
site on this side so they can pretend
Dylan Dan said this he's like whoa what
the [ __ ] interests anything racist right
you want to justify his actions right do
you believe do you to switch gears do
you believe our boy Derrick Lewis do you
believe that he actually only trains a
half hour a day yeah I do yeah I don't
know if half an hour but I don't maybe
an hour and I don't think you know I
think he knows his only chance to win
fights is land that big right hand he
kind of does that when he was on my show
I asked I was like dude I think they
were retired like once you've done and
he was Bannen Josie comment made me an
offer for way more money so I was like
[ __ ] it all so where was he fighting
before that he was in the UFC but he was
retired okay so he left he was like I'm
done after his magazine after Mark Hunt
and then they call him with more money
is that guy's good amount of money I'll
do it
so now you know them he'll make seven
figures fine DC DC is gonna make a good
amount of money too you know obviously
DC you make more money
listen she's gotta take a pound and
expose
him he is bitter for but he is but if
you're if you're Derek Lewis it's not a
bit moon it's not a bad gig you're
probably not gonna get a title shot
offered with your fighting style unless
you win a few more and it's always it's
always a toss-up for him yeah and you
get a fight DC DC as the heavyweights
you know he did knock out steep base so
there's some power there but just take
you down you know but let listen Derek
Lewis had a plus 800 underdog that's not
a bad bat he lands that right hand it
puts anybody to sleep less 800 put a
grand on that dude million base he has
he knocked out everybody he's fought
know you want the decision with Roy
Nelson the Francis a got anything was
bad yeah France and Ghana to is the
worst fighting everybody
besides my last ski fight but this is
bad I don't you got chin okay this is a
quick one on Selena Gomez you guys are
talking about the heart transplant
changing your personality
yeah I wonder if this is sort of related
cuz so he almost had her kidney replaced
remember that her friend donated her own
kidney we said a heart bro I'm just
saying internal organs important organs
so she's been dealing with some crazy
emotional breakdown recently her she had
like difficulties with that kidney
transplant I guess she had like low
white blood cell count this is two weeks
ago it's the Biebs he's married dude
broke her heart
Oh or she's taken with the Biebs moving
on painkillers and fame there's your
[ __ ] the Biebs is taking it hard to a
lot of her like a famous man taking it
hard
huh the Biebs is taking what hard her
her going through an emotional breakdown
really yeah is he taking it out on his
girlfriend's [ __ ] chin right now late I
apologize all the listeners in you it's
a little late it's late okay but when he
said the Biebs is taking it hard to I
just don't buy it
cuz seem in these rap videos now he's
doing fine he's just fine looks good I
had to look up that girl from that video
she's got it going on there his yes a
how did you Jack crying non-stop Brown
just be were seen crying with Haley
Baldwin after saying going he's crying
because his bank count so far
he's crying cuz he's insanely huge hog
that's what he's crying his life is
great yeah he seems like a changed man
with what the whole church stuff I'm a
fan of them he's always been very
religious right I think he started
finding God yeah cuz he was he was like
wild he was really wild before
yeah he's wild God seems like it so this
is church friends I've kid is it too
talented anyway I don't know what to say
about that
almost Lima Gomez fan she's great in
Transylvania is all three she's the
voice of a girl vampire did not yep and
she can sing her ass off okay Jamie
Lovato still [ __ ] popping painkillers
was she doing I think she back to should
I greet her right she's still she's
still not so I she's got she's had some
problems for many many years apparently
I'm a fan of her she's still in rehab
yeah alright anything else one more last
one I think this is funny so Kanye when
he was at the White House he pulled out
his phone in front of cameras and you
can see his access code to his phone
it's just zeros play the video yeah
check this up Oh what kind of haters
filming me I mean there's tons of
filming he's all zeros this right here
that was the main thing is you have an
enormous conversation with all those
cameras and everything Trump loves it
Trump can just hang to everybody can't
he just say yeah I don't know if this
was planned I don't think so but imagine
you're Kanye West would you have your
phone zero zero zero zero zero or
whatever happens I've known he was gonna
do it so he's like I'm a changes that's
probably it they he's not that soy or he
just know so yeah everyone's given a
hard time about it
that's hilarious yeah that's it
hey hoops that did it again
gonna be at the Hillcrest Art Center in
Thousand Oaks doing some stand-up I
don't know how many people had seats but
just doing it display yourself just by
myself just go on and do some stand-up
just gonna set up a mic and just start
talking if you guys show up you show up
are you the Bordas man in the world I
somebody I want to do it it seems like a
good room um cool dude have fun in Salt
Lake City
next week I'm in Salt Lake City Thursday
Friday Saturday Salt Lake City shows are
almost sold out t fat K calm after that
Cobb San Francisco November 2nd and 3rd
after that 16 17 I'm Sacramento then New
York City the end of the mud New York
City get your takes down comedy comedy
club get them and this week I think
tomorrow what's it smell Friday yes sir
tamal presale tickets for my shooting my
Showtime County special January 18th and
San Diego Spreckels theatre two shows on
Saturday few birdies might be opening up
for me I don't know it's what I hear
famous birdies a couple of guys these
two guys you guys have heard of her
gonna be opening up tickets go on sale
tomorrow I think if not I'll be tuned
into my social media and chablis post
them out but so let's be available
tomorrow what I heard probably buddy
thanks dude very excited all right guys
love you this is a fine kid we're out